[Music]
and in a moment like this I ask myself
why why do I put myself through the
embarassing pain wearing a special
cycling suit designed to keep my
genitalia raised above my belly button
to the hints I go for eight hours upper
yield 1200 metres above sea level at not
eats chicken's ass dance with a man
named Shaw Shaw who would soon have an
entire community of new friends hey show
show show show
hey show show show show show yeah call
the water let's look at the house 48
hours ago I flew to a small town on the
east coast of Taiwan with my surfboard
and an overnight bag
I just needed to get away for a couple
of days
this was course after the race that was
straight back into the chaos and I
uncovered this with Cecile
welcome to the heart of Asia I'm in
Taipei Taiwan if you're so confused as
to what the seed envelope is that's
totally cool
I brought this global map which you can
find are not normal set up on where you
plan to see you which is an unfinished
idea in your city
each week I choose a news I applied to
that city and completed with you the
sweet seed is from show show together we
should become king of the mountain you
come on welcome to my new weekly show
nuts normal food service my brainy
secrets this beautiful action not the
switch mystery to say
Taiwan is a beautiful island 100 miles
off the coast of China with a rich yet
turbulent political history
even today Taiwan is officially called
the Republic of China that's odd isn't
it
sovereignty of the island has changed
hands many times first colonized by the
Dutch in the 17th century
then overthrown by the Chinese then the
Japanese and then the hosted KMT led
Republic of China party in 1949 they
took up residence and ran the show
dictatorship style lasting 50 years to
the year 2000 from then Taiwan has
democratized and its leaders have all
backed independence from China who
regard Taiwan as a breakaway province
which it is vowed to retake by force if
necessary
[Music]
flying Taiwan's flag in China can lead
to a wreck and you can behold for long
periods of time without being formally
charged a threat which today's
protesters in Hong Kong may very well
face buying the Taiwanese flag at events
around the world is often the salaah
under the one China policy as is
Taiwan's participation at many world
events China threatens to block
international companies if they fail to
list Taiwan as part of China on their
websites and China still adamantly
refuses for Taiwan to represent itself
at the UN let's see for ourselves what
Taiwan has to offer
[Music]
[Music]
thank you you can keep the change
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
do you ever have cars
[Music]
so tell me about you see sure you have
seen what's happening Hong Kong and I
want to make sure this doesn't happen to
Taiwan you may think I'm crazy
might takes a crazy person to make all
the change show show is indeed one of
the crazy ones brave enough to make a
difference six years ago he decided to
cycle from Taipei Taiwan to Cape Town
South Africa spread the word about
Taiwan's independence
foreigners
this took him two years he is an hour
back in Taiwan working on doing guided
bicycle tours for tourists but with all
of China's red tape it makes it really
difficult to use traditional style media
to spread his word so my CDs to invite
you to beat a king of the mountain was
likely one of the toughest psychopaths
in the world
I guess the bigger picture for his seed
is to showcase the beauty Taiwan has to
offer through my video but these seeds
are more about creating deeply rooted
longer lasting relationships with people
and therefore it's only fitting to take
this idea further
[Music]
I told show so that the idea of the
cycling up the mountain would be really
fun and even though it was about to be I
had a much greater surprise in store so
the next day while shershow believed I
was at home mentally preparing for the
painful 60 mile cycle of the hill I
secretly met with his wife and
translator TK I cut the inner scoop on
his idealization of filmmaker Peter
MacKinnon then when shopping for
t-shirts ekron stickers and other
celebratory objects I got on the phone
with Peter and Alma's KC other youtubers
business advisors and a designer to plan
the match bigger picture short rotate to
pinch me at the crack of dawn the next
morning to start this mammoth of a cycle
he rarely kids at me out
[Music]
you ride through the mountainside made
me appreciate sure sure as a human being
even more constantly positive just such
a great dude
we gotta go through the mist we
continued through the night adamant to
finish it's freezing cold it's now 9:30
p.m.
[Music]
is that the first line and when we go to
the finish line
his wife was waiting there to take him
back to the studio for the real reward
[Music]
[Applause]
this one will make sense now and then
come in okay it's coming
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
hey show show Peter McKinnon here how
are you doing man how are you doing
you're probably tired because you just
wrote a bike up a mountain which is
insane
but congratulations on becoming king of
the mountain purges you started a
YouTube channel which is awesome so if
you ever need any help or need anything
let me know hit me up email phone would
love to chat with you and hopefully I
get to meet you one of these days
because hope you've got quite the
journey ahead my friend you're gonna
love it and all you're gonna do is just
get that first video up just get those
first few videos going and the rest will
follow
you got this I'll see you on the
Internet I'll see you on YouTube that's
where I'll see you please hey Shosh ll
miles yes I want to say welcome to you
that's super setting that you're making
videos inside a channel now I can't wait
to see the stuff to make I'm to
subscribe and like every single video
and this that's just very super fine I'm
good lucky man can't wait to see stuff
show show welcome to YouTube
Congrats little marks on the chip also
congrats on being king of the mountain
alright I'll see you I'll see you on the
Internet show show echo to do the area
51 guards they won't find you here I
have this place unlisted in the phone
hey Oh show show what's good brother
Congrats on starting your YouTube
channel please be me anything
feel free to help feel free to reach out
feel free to hit me up if you need any
advice I'm here to help you any advice
on either feel free to let me know
welcome to YouTube I'll show so what's
up there it's Fabio from epidemics at
NYC I'm here with the team we're excited
about all the stuff in Taiwan we're sad
about your new channel and want to give
you special talent I'll give you one
here a three epidemic sound and why
[Applause]
[Music]
this would be
also for quite a long time and yeah we
keep trying to find something magical
happen the YouTube channel we created
show sure to spread his beautiful
messages about Taiwan's independence
freely and globally is now live
please go give him and Taiwan the
support they deserve
[Music]
[Applause]
oops
before I in this video I just want to
update you on what's actually going on
here I just arrived back in New York
City I'm busy working on the next seed
this entire journey has been non-stop
but incredible exciting news the
website's is now in Phase two which
means that you can contact the seeds
that you find compelling and we've added
a search bar so that you can easily find
the seeds that you're interested in not
normal it's about the unbelievable
possibility of connection afforded to us
and the importance of collaboration
sometimes you have the ability but not
the idea and sometimes you just need to
push from a fellow creative mind use the
mouth to connect with like-minded
creatives around the globe and make the
incredible happen and lastly this one
week left to enter my road real I was
lucky enough to win it back in 2016 with
my full gift which has been a big step
in my career as a young phone Darington
and now three years later
I'm a judge and I'm super excited to see
all your firms as I said there's only
one week left to enter so go to wwm I
rode real calm and submit your phones
within the next week or else you can
just click on the link below
other than that don't forget your
awesome varium and I'll see you next
week Wednesday I just want to say a huge
thank you to my sponsors B&H Photo Video
don't forget to subscribe to check out
next week's video
plastic pollution in San Francisco
[Music]